[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
brace yourself tommy lee takes a ride on
the wild side posting a not safe for
work photo of his well
nether region
um
well i wish i had some sort of method to
the madness because it's never really
the same you don't expect to see this
one scrolling down your feed but this is
tommy we're talking about and shocking
us is nothing new he posted this fully
nude pic we had to censor his caption a
cheeky oops
and in the comments his wife brittany
ferland says exactly what's on our minds
oh my god yeah it was pretty damn sexy
we can't say for sure but knowing tommy
feels like this post was no accident the
59 year old isn't exactly shy i feel
like i'm just a young spirited
dude who
refuses to move forward the full frontal
selfie has since been deleted from the
musician's instagram page because it
violates their no nudity policy but the
pick is still up on his twitter
meanwhile tommy's seemingly running with
the theme posting memes like this one of
a buddha statue holding a banana
then there's this one of an elephant
staring at a naked man asking how do you
breathe through that little thing
it's a it's a blur
now the motley crew rocker's latest post
isn't exactly a total surprise fans of
the musician know he's got a long
hollywood history of racy behavior what
the hell is this
of course there's his infamous sex tape
with his ex pamela anderson this is
forever this is forever i've never felt
like this before i've never felt like
this in my life
tommy's relationship with the former
playmate and that video are highlighted
in the emmy nominated hulu series pam
and tommy every second it passes this
tape could be spreading baby we will get
it back
last year tommy told e.t how he felt
about sebastian stan stepping into his
shoes i know sebastian he's playing me
and
from what he's told me it's a really
beautiful story yeah like
you know i think a lot of people would
think that it's one thing
but it's really about uh about uh
privacy and how things
got crazy it tells me it's pretty it's
pretty wild well judging by his latest
not safe for work post wild is right up
tommy's alley
[Music]
[Applause]